spiele fans und solche die es noch
werden wollen fieberten gestern abend
der großen präsentation der playstation
5 entgegen die präsentation fand statt
groß war sie allerdings nicht warum der
abend enttäuschte gleich jetzt aber erst
einmal die positiven dinge des abends
und martin eisenlauer ist mir jetzt
zugeschaltet um über den arm zu sprechen
der dann doch enttäuschend war oder
martin wir alle haben gehofft auf ein
erscheinungsdatum auf einen preis auf
weitere technische details und dann gab
es viele bunte bilder an dem abend oder
ja hallo moritz ja also wir fans hatten
gehofft dass wir endlich erfahren was
das ding denn dann können wird und was
es kosten soll wenn der urlaub planen
sollen damit wir direkt nach dem start
los spielen können und ja ganz viel
davon hat eben gestern nicht
stattgefunden
sony hat über eine stunde lang videos zu
neuen spielen gezeigt wirklich tolle
spiele auch gezeigt aber am ende das was
wir wirklich wissen wollten nämlich was
kostet das ab wann geht's los
haben sie uns leider nicht verraten
tolle spiele haben sie gezeigt wir haben
gerade das äußere der playstation 5
gesehen konnte man noch irgendwas
zumindest zwischen den zeilen gestern
von dieser präsentation erfahren
rauslesen ja es gab so ein paar kleine
details was sehr spannend ist es scheint
2 playstation 5 ist zu geben also ein
modell mit einem klassischen laufwerk wo
man also eine disc einschiebt und dann
wird das spiel installiert und ein
modell das digital edition heißt das
offenbar ohne laufwerk aus kommt also
die spiele nur noch aus dem internet
bekommt wer heute schon eine playstation
hat kennt den prozess ja schon dass man
spiele inzwischen eigentlich herunter
lädt als sie tatsächlich noch physisch
im laden zu kaufen
dem trägt sony der offensichtliche
rechnung und es gab noch so ja ich würde
mal sagen versteckt kleine hinweise wann
es losgehen soll
bei einigen spielen stand eben drin man
die tatsächlich kommen sollen und der
früheste termin der angegeben wurde war
herbst 2020 nicht wie viele erwartet
hatten erst winter oder zu weihnachten
2020 aber ja was immer das bedeuten mag
oder vielleicht es ist auch einfach nur
eine schlechte information die da noch
stand wir wissen es leider eben nicht
und ja das ist das schade ist also bis
zum herbst 2020 haben wir noch zeit zu
sparen auf die playstation fünf wie viel
müssen wir denn ansparen um sie uns
leisten zu können weiß man ungefähr
zumindest eine preisspanne
ja ich glaube sie wird definitiv nicht
unter 500 euro kosten und wahrscheinlich
auch nicht über 1000 das ist momentan so
ein bisschen katz und maus spiel das
sich da microsoft und sony liefern weil
die beiden eben jeweils darauf warten
was der andere macht also jeder möchte
mit der seiner neuen konsole der sein
der dann auch nicht nur die bessere
sondern auch noch die günstigere konsole
im weihnachtsgeschäft anbietet und
deswegen warten gerade beide in der
hoffnung dass irgendjemand irgendwann
mal sagt okay das ist unser preis punkt
und dann ich möchte wetten drei vier
tage danach maximal kommt der andere und
sagt übrigens wir sind noch mal ein paar
euro günstiger